avez-vous écrit une vie pour vous justifier
[Applaudissements]
je suis très fier de ma vie et de toutes les
choses que j'ai faites et je ne l'ai pas écrite pour
cette raison
je l'ai écrite pour revoir ma vie à
la fin de ta vie  vous
rêvez parfois en vous demandant
ce que vous avez fait et comment
vous avez vu mais vous savez quand vous dites la
vérité toute la vérité et rien d'autre
que la vérité
comme vous dites que vous l'avez fait n'êtes-vous pas obligé de
blesser certaines personnes
que vous blessez  les gens pour la première
fois
de ma vie j'ai dit ce que je pensais d'un
certain nombre de personnes et ils étaient un peu
contrariés je ne dirais pas qu'ils ont été mortellement
blessés je veux dire qu'ils vont récupérer
mais au moins ils savent ce que je pense et
je pars  à la tombe d'avoir dit
tout ce que je ressens
me dire est-ce que les acteurs ont attendu le
studio de l'acteur pour leur dire quel était leur
lien
d'un rôle avec leur propre vie j'ai
été acteur pendant huit ans
et j'ai appris très vite que la meilleure
façon de  comprendre quelque chose dans la scène
est de comprendre euh quelque chose de similaire
ce qui s'est passé pour vous
dites-moi s'il y a une méthode pour découvrir
pourquoi brando dean
montgomery clift et warren beatty sont
devenus des stars
non j'ai été très surpris par tout le monde
sauf brando je savais que brando serait une
star
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que jimmy dean soit une star
mais il  était plein de talent il avait
un talent énorme mais je ne m'attendais pas à
être un star
warren beatty quand j'ai commencé c'était juste
un gamin
euh je connaissais très bien cliff parce que cliff
avait une mère obsédée par ma femme il avait l'habitude
de s'asseoir à ses pieds  et
et la regarder et lui demander conseil
et ainsi de suite
et je savais à quel point il était sensible mais
il y a un élément qui
m'échappe chez tous ces hommes qui est que je
ne comprends pas pourquoi les
femmes trouvent l'apparence de certains hommes
attirée
je ne sais pas je  Je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit l'
apparence, c'est peut-être quelque chose qui a
un pouvoir en eux. Je pense que les femmes sont
essentiellement attirées
par le pouvoir, pas l'apparence, pas l'apparence.
je ne le ressens pas chez ces hommes
parce que euh
je ne suis pas attiré par ça en particulier
comment
expliquez-vous comment jimmy dean qui est un tel
morveux
est devenu une si grande star ça me bouscule
la raison est qu'il euh à cette époque les
jeunes jeunes  les hommes en particulier étaient
très agités avec l'
autorité de leur père et avec euh
avec le système et euh jimmy dean était
l'incarnation de la
rébellion adolescente mais je ne pense pas
beaucoup à la
rébellion adolescente je ne suis pas impressionné
par ça j'aime la rébellion plus tard dans la vie
où  il a un vrai but et jimmy
jimmy n'était que le mauvais garçon du
quartier et les
jeunes y ont réagi, en particulier les
femmes inhibées,
ils ont réagi, ils ont senti mon dieu
c'est moi qu'est-ce que tu penses que c'était qui a
fait que orson welles
et marlon brando obtiennent  si grossier si gros
je me suis posé cette question plusieurs
fois
j'ai posé cette question à tennessee williams
une fois qu'il a dit une chose terrible que je
n'ai jamais oubliée
il a dit du dégoût de soi ou de la colère contre
eux
-mêmes et ensuite ils n'obtiennent pas  plus de plaisir de la
vie et le seul plaisir qu'ils
obtiennent finalement est de se gaver
et de manger et ainsi de suite tu as dit dans le
livre qu'un an après
ton témoignage devant la
maison sur le comité des activités américaines
tu as cessé de te sentir coupable
tu as même dit que tu  cessé de se
sentir coupable des mois
seulement quelques mois après est-ce
vrai
non mais environ deux mois après quand
euh
j'ai perdu quelques amis j'ai perdu quelques
amis dont
je ne me sens pas privé j'ai oublié je l'ai
oublié et je  arrêté de se sentir coupable, vous
ne pouvez pas vivre une vie sur la culpabilité
et quand j'y ai pensé, j'ai pensé que j'avais
bien fait même si c'était difficile,
ce n'était pas un choix simple parfois vous
dites ceci ou cela et l'un est noir et
l'autre blanc c'était
Ce n'est pas quelque chose comme ça, est-il possible que
parce que tu étais le fils d'un
marchand de tapis, un marchand de tapis, tu avais besoin de
te venger de la
population blanche anglo-saxonne
de l'école et de la société où
tu évoluais, j'ai senti que je  a été
méprisé un peu je vois quand
j'étais à l'université
j'étais serveur quatre ans j'ai servi
à table et j'ai apporté de la nourriture aux
privilégiés
à ceux qui avaient assez d'argent pour payer
leur chemin et ainsi de suite et puis je suis allé
au théâtre  l'école et j'ai travaillé le
lave-vaisselle
donc tout le temps j'ai senti que j'étais l'un
des euh
comment appelez-vous ça euh étranger et euh
naturellement il est inévitable qu'il y ait
un sentiment que
maintenant j'ai renversé les rôles sur vous
n'avez-vous pas  es-tu toujours un étranger
euh je ne pense pas non qu'est-ce que tu
te dis tous les matins quand tu te regardes
dans le miroir
il y a une histoire célèbre à propos d'un juge
de la cour suprême en amérique
oliver wendell holmes et il avait 80
ans comme  j'ai 80 ans
et il marchait dans la rue un
jour et une belle fille a croisé une jeune
fille avec tout parfait en place
et ainsi de suite
et il l'a regardée et il a dit à l'
homme qui marchait avec lui il a dit
oh  avoir à nouveau 70 ans parfois j'ai l'impression d'avoir à
nouveau 70 ans  tu te souviens de
ton père qui t'a dit avec
ton visage que tu ne serais jamais acteur
il a dit qu'est ce que tu vas faire à l'
école de théâtre de yale j'ai dit que j'allais
étudier le théâtre
il a dit tu ne t'es pas regardé dans le
miroir  dans le livre
une vie où le talent comme la beauté
disparaît la vérité non mon c'est le meilleur
livre que j'ai
écrit l'autobiographie que j'ai écrite est de loin
le meilleur livre que j'ai écrit c'est complètement
véridique
mais ça vient d'où il m'a fallu quatre ans pour l'
écrire
j'ai travaillé tous  jour pendant quatre ans et
aussi j'étais déterminé à être honnête et
clair
et à ne pas éviter
aucun problème je suis très dur avec moi-même
beaucoup de gens qui ont revu mon livre en
Amérique les critiques ont dit que
je suis plus dur avec moi-même que n'importe quel critique
ne l'a jamais été  c'est vrai
supposons une vie ta vie devait être vécue à
nouveau
que feriez-vous différemment je commencerais à
écrire plus tôt